given the data that you have seen is
there any reason to think a rate
increase on October 28th is possible or
is October really off the table well you
know one of the things that I principles
I follow is that I do a lot of analysis
do a lot of thinking with my team in San
Francisco read a lot of the reports and
briefing materials we get from our
colleagues around the Federal Reserve
but the decision around interest rates
and policy decisions take place out the
meeting and when I get into me tonight I
share my views and what I've learned but
I also listen to my colleagues and we
try to gather come to a consensus
decision so what that decision will be
really is to be driven by what are those
conversations and all the factors that
were weighing at the at the meetings in
the future what's John Williams going to
tell them about his view well my view is
basically on the employment mandate side
we've seen huge progress on the job
market unemployment's down to close to
five percent close to what I think of
his full employment inflations running
below our target and that's a
significant consideration but I think we
understand why that's happening mainly
due to the strong dollar the decline in
oil prices and so I do see an economy
that is strengthened we're basically at
one of our mandates but still there are
risks and uncertainties there and and
anything important thing to think about
is it's not just about our first move to
raise interest rates it's really that I
think we're going to need an
accommodative monetary policy for
another few years so even when we do
start that process of raising rates it's
still gonna be the case that monetary
conditions are pretty pretty
accommodative and supportive of
continued growth what do you think would
you vote put it that way for an interest
rate increase on the twenty-eighth I'm
not going again speculate about how what
oh my views are for that meeting again
we start the process really of the deep
dive briefings starts tomorrow for us
and I spend a whole week preparing for
the meeting and we'll get a lot of
materials and again get listening to my
colleagues so I'm not going to decide on
that today well right now as we speak
the 10-year note yield is two point O
two percent if you were to vote for an
increase in October it would shock the
markets is a Fed willing to do that I
think what we need to do is focus on
economic fundamentals where the economy
is the progress we made on our dual
mandate goals and where we see that
economy going over the next couple years
an important consideration is it takes
about a year or two for monetary policy
actions to have their full effects on
the economy so we always have to be
looking to the through the front window
and not back in the rearview mirror and
thinking about our policy decision
interesting that you know that
minneapolis fed president ariana
Kocherlakota has suggested the slowdown
we're seeing now in hiring and spending
is really the long and variable lags in
monetary policy taking a fact from the
Fed's decision to begin tapering way
back in mid-2013 well my own view is
that the economy is still on a good
trajectory growth is my my forecast
continuing to be a two percent or above
that for GDP growth I still expect
continued job gains and unemployment to
come down below five percent by late
this year or early next year so I still
think we're on a good trajectory I think
it's actually a healthy sign that the
pace of growth is slowing a bit because
if we kept adding jobs at the pace of
last year and the first half of this
year we would be in danger of really
significantly overshooting the mark so
my view is the economy still in a good
trajectory I think some of the slowdown
in jobs really is because of the
strengthening of the dollar and other
things are other factors so I'm not so
worried about the the slowdown in some
of the recent data again it's supportive
of continuing improvement in the labor
market the Atlanta Fed GDP tracker
suggests we're going to see zero point
nine nine tenths of a percent growth for
the third quarter is that too low do you
need to see something higher in order to
support the case for higher rates well
my mantra I'm looking at data is not to
get too caught up into the month a month
quarter core movements because there's a
lot of volatility there q2 growth was
three-point-nine percent way above trend
and of course there's some payback in
the third quarter and my view is the
growth in the second half of this year
will be about two percent at an annual
rate so again on a good trajectory but
again ma che policy takes a year or two
to have its effect so you don't want to
get caught up in this month's data or
this borders data stay focused on the
outlook over the next year or two well
has your forecast for 2016 for the first
half or for the entire year come down
with the slowing in growth this fall no
in fact my forecast in terms of the
unemployment rate is actually come down
a little bit because we've seen
unemployment come down quicker than we
expected and also other indicators of
labor market have continued to improve
at a really healthy clip my view on the
GDP growth next year is for growth to be
around two to two and a quarter percent
that hasn't really changed and my view
is the inflation will come back to two
percent over the next couple years and
that really hasn't changed obviously the
near term inflation outlook has been
held down by the strength of the dollar
in oil prices well where does it leave
you in terms of having a decision to
raise rates by the end of this year you
have suggested that you sort of expected
that to happen if the data come in as
you forecast well again this is my own
my own view on this but you know we
expect to see unemployment get down to
about 5% and dip below that later this
year early next year I see expect to see
continuing signs that inflation is
stabilized and maybe underlying
inflation is moving back towards 2% so
in that context zero interest rates in
the extraordinary accommodation we have
in place I don't think it's necessary to
continue to support growth so I do see
the time to start raising rates in the
in the near future from my perspective
but we're going to watch the data and
obviously listen to all the information
that I hear from my colleagues and and
from all my contacts in the community